Also, Raymond Ibraham, one of the
world's leading experts on all things
radical Islam in the Islamic invasion
and takeover of Europe, joins us from
Budapest. Raymond, thank you so much uh
for joining us. You're also besides
being a best-selling author and one of
the most beloved uh guest on the war
room over the years as you've put out
three books since you've been uh joining
us about uh Islamic invasions. You're
also a fellow is it at the Danube
Institute in Budapest, sir?
>> Yes, I am, Steve. Uh, for this year,
I've I'm visiting fellow at the Danube
Institute. Great place and a lot of
resources to work with.
So, you know, why is Hungary
have uh an institute that has Raymond
Ibraham as a as a senior fellow for a
year and why is it appropriate to have
you on at least once a week in War Run,
Texas about Sharia law and uh and the
invasion? Um and particularly the
governor in our state led got in front
of the president and in front of
Governor DeSantis in Florida and he
designated the Muslim Brotherhood as a
terrorist organization. In fact, he
designated an international terrorist
organization that's going to be
investigated and driven out of Texas
along with CARE. Your your thoughts
about all that, sir. Particularly about
uh these Islamic invasions.
It
>> it's just Islam is growing and they
can't keep the cat in the bag anymore.
uh they've done when the Muslim
population and the Muslim presence in
the west was small and it was still
doing what it was doing of course they
played cover for it and Islamophobia and
multiculturalism and diversity etc etc
but in as much as Islam grows and
obviously here in Europe it's uh it's
it's where it's reached critical mass it
becomes too hard for them to cover up so
it's become really an issue and people
are starting to see it everywhere from
the UK uh all throughout the scand
Scandinavia and Germany and France and
wherever you're getting these large
Muslim populations you're seeing what's
what comes along with them which is we
can say Sharia because uh and by the way
that word you know gets thrown around a
lot and I think it's important for
people to understand its etmology and
its meaning and uh in its origin as as
with so many Islamic words um Arabic
words they really go back to sort of 7th
century Bedawin tribalism from the time
of Muhammad and all the the the
trilateral roots of the Word Sharia
Shara means uh watering spot for your
camel. Okay, so you're in the desert.
Where is life? So Sharia is the road to
life. Okay, it's where you get water in
these extremely desiccated and parched
regions. So it's understood as life. So
what does that mean? It means Allah's
way for to have you live your life and
to live the proper life which is just
all these rules and laws as found in the
Quran and um as in the Sunnah enshrined
in the Sunnah based on the hadith the
words of sayings of Muhammad and in
short this is why I find it interesting
because I hear some people acting like
Islam is its own thing and Muslims and
then Sharia is another thing as if to be
a Muslim is not to practice Sharia but
well saying saying a Muslim not does not
necessarily have practice Sharia is like
saying a Muslim doesn't have to believe
in the Quran or follow the Quran. So
they are intertwined. They're really one
and the same in many ways. Islam is
Sharia and vice versa. You can say that.
So of course every Muslim when they come
this is why I also find it interesting
in some of the laws that I'm seeing
proposed they're against Sharia which is
good all well and good but in a sense if
they understood the deeper context the
way I'm trying to explain it well you're
really saying you're against Islam. And
uh so it's kind of interesting because
Muslims are allowed to migrate to
Western nations in the United States,
but they have to leave Sharia at home,
which is fine. I mean, if you can do
that, but the fact is if you're a Muslim
in and of yourself, that means you've
submitted to the law of Allah, the law
of life, which is Sharia. So anyway, I
think Islam is becoming a huge issue and
it's spilling over, especially with
what's happening in Texas, that epic
city which is now, I think, called the
Meadows. Um and and we should at some
point I'll take a break right here and
let you talk but we should talk about
the concept of alabat because this is
exactly what these are. These enclaves
are historical rabbots which were
essentially jihadist fortifications
intentionally placed right on the
frontier of infidel territory.
>> I want to get to that uh in a moment.
Let me let me go back to the argument
before I bring Joan in in also the
argument that um hey you've got freedom
of religion in the United States. They
don't make this argument in Europe
anymore. It's interesting. They used to
make it a lot. You can't uh you couldn't
do anything with the Muslims because
you're imposing on their religion. But
now that they've got critical mass or
they're beginning to get critical mass
in France and in the Netherlands uh and
in the United Kingdom, you don't hear
that argument anymore. I mean, they're
beyond that. They're they're brazen in
uh in what they propose uh the
imposition of Sharia law and how they're
going to just they have no go zones.
They're just going to run it. The
police, the the town council, all of it.
But what about this argument uh that
you've seen thrown up? Well, it's just a
religion and if you're going to let
Christianity uh you're going to help
Christianity flourish uh you can't uh
you can't suppress uh Islam. Your your
your thoughts to that?
No,
>> Christianity can flourish without us
necessarily doing anything uh active.
Just let Christians preach, let them
live their lives. But Islam is is
codified with rules, the active rules
that you have to do. Okay? So we know
for so for example things like prayer
and fasting, you know, the five pillars
of Islam, those are Sharia. But there's
other things as well, which is for
example, um killing the apostate. Okay?
So Christians don't do that. That's why
you can Christianity can flourish side
by side with what is perceived as
secular governance whereas true Sharia
true Islam cannot. Same thing with
blasphemy laws. And uh this I think is
something that Islam and the so-called
left actually have in common with each
other because they both do believe in uh
you know squashing free speech about
anything they don't like. And that's
exactly what Islam's blasphemy laws are.
Um so maybe the left is fine with that
to that sense. But as you can see in a
strictly true free country, a free
democracy with freedom of speech, you
can't have something like blasphemy
codes even though it is completely
enshrined in Islam. And then you also
have okay Christianity is is monogamous
by nature and that's sort of what we
have right now. Well, if you allow Islam
now you have polygamy up to four wives
and also uh concubines, infidels who are
enslaved and your right hand possesses
according to the Quran. So I think
that's the problem. Christianity can
flourish and it still walks side by side
with the law whereas Islam because it is
its own law. Okay, secular western law
developed side by side with
Christianity. So the two are very much
synchronized in a sense or at least they
were in in their founding and origin.
But Islam is a very alien hostile
different creed. And as I just mentioned
to you just a few of the things that are
completely honor killings. for example,
they're not in Sharia law, but of
course, they're part of the culture as
well. So, you get a lot of this baggage
that um I don't think it's it's
completely comparing apples and oranges
when people say Christianity and Islam,
it's the same thing.
>> When they when they uh when Muslims take
become citizens and swear allegiance to
the United States and to the
Constitution, can they actually do that?
I know there's a concept in Islam that
you can you can lie to the infidel and
there's not a problem as long as you're
promoting Islam. But can a a a Muslim
actually take to become a citizen of the
United States? Can they actually swear
allegiance to the Constitution and to
our republic and actually be a Muslim in
good standing?
>> Yes, they can do it. But just like you
said, they can do it as a part of TGA.
uh which means okay the the original
teaching the original law is you have to
actually have always hatred for
non-Muslims this is in the Quran 64
chapter surah 60 and a4 which where it
talks about Ibraim Abraham and how he's
a good example to every Muslim because
he said to his people we hate and
renounce you and enmity you will last
forever until you believe in Allah okay
so that's the standing principle if
you're a non-Muslim you are to be
disliked and hated okay and just to
really underscore this our good friends
and allies Saudi Arabia and Qatar many
years ago I found on their websites
their official governmental websites
because in those nations of course
Sharia and the government are one and
the same they're sponsored by the
government they actually had fatwas
talking about how you have to hate
Americans or or and every any everyone
but they also spoke about Americans
because they're infidels and this is the
doctrine it's known as loyalty and
enmity or alwah in Arabic um but again
to give you an idea but at the same time
Saudi Arabia comes and dances with US
presidents and European leaders and
dances with their swords and kiss each
other. So how do they reconcile that as
well? And also you cannot you cannot
pledge allegiance to an infidel
willingly unless you do it as a lie. And
this again is tea. So if you do it to
preserve your life or as a strategen
then that is legitimate. Muhammad
himself did this. So strictly speaking,
when a Muslim comes and pledges
allegiance to America, okay, that is
completely unislamic, but it is Islamic
for him to do it as a ruse or or as a or
or if he feigns if he feains loyalty and
he does it in the context of tea, that
is 100% legitimate. So on the one hand,
Muslims are commanded not to befriend
and not to um associate and certainly
not to be loyal to non-Muslims. But on
the other hand, there is this little
caveat where and it's played out all
throughout history. This is one of the
major reasons behind the Inquisition for
example in Spain because Muslims had
converted nominally, but they were still
working with jihadist groups like the
Ottomans and the Barbarie pirates
subvert Spain. So this has happened
multiple times and um yeah I mean of
course a Muslim can tell me hey I
pledged allegiance to America and I
believe it but good for him but that
does not accord with strict Islamic
teaching which does say you cannot I can
pull up the Quran verse I think it's
3:28 which says um you cannot be loyal
and it names you know the non-Muslims
and and another one it says you have to
hate the Christians and the Jews and you
cannot be loyal to them and then it says
unless it's by way of precaution which
is the which is the concept of tea,
which is you're basically lying. Um
because it's in your own benefit.
>> They've come in they come into these
societies on cat's paws, right? They
come in at first, but then they reach a
critical mass. You just can't hide it.
That's what's happening in Texas. That's
why people are trying to get ahead of
this. The governor has designated the
Muslim Brotherhood and CARE as
international terrorist organization. He
said there's been massive investigations
going on even as we speak by the
authorities in Texas to get to the
bottom of all this particularly what
they've been doing in Texas. But they
have been building there's two mosque
per month I think in North Texas 301
mosque overall the majority of those I
believe in in the hu greater Houston
area and in the Dallas Fort Worth
metroplex and particularly north of
Dallas. But you talked about this is a
concept they've used before. Talk to me
about uh like Epic City or now called
the Meadows. They they look at these as
garrisons on the on the frontier of the
infidels to ultimately look at taking
over their societies and converting uh
converting people to Islam.
>> Yeah. So historically what happened is
wherever Muslim jihadists would conquer
uh non-Muslim territories which were a
great amount as we know of course all of
the Christian uh North Africa and the
Middle East were conquered in the 7th
century. Wherever they were stopped by
non-Muslims, there they would form
garrisons and fortifications. In Arabic,
it's known as and it comes from a word
which means like a tight fastening or a
rope. And it's also in the Quran it says
form a rabbot to become successful. And
basically it would just be a they would
become they would be jihadist par
excellence and they would be right on
the frontier zones. And there were
multiple frontier zones historically in
Asia Minor and Anatolia in the north and
south in the middle of Spain because
north Spain was primarily Christian at
that point and in the south and this was
would be an area of constant warfare.
Okay. So what's happening now the the
parallel is um now Muslims are not
forming these fortifications wherever
infidels stop them. Infidels are
welcoming them in right in the middle of
their societies and they're building
organically. This is why I say it's not
even that they're consciously trying to
build a rabbot. It's just when I see it,
it's an organic manifestation of the
rebot concept because it's primarily
Muslim. It's an enclave. It's a hot bed
of radicalization. You see this in
Europe. You're going to see it in in
Texas. Uh especially if these things
come to pass and the growth that you
see. And it's also it's where you know
in and of itself when you think about it
when any any people does this Muslims or
otherwise when they come to a country
like the United States and the first
thing they want to do is just set up
shop away from everyone else so it's
just their own thing that that itself to
me I mean everyone has to understand and
understand what this is. It's just these
are opportunistic people at the least
who are saying we want all the good
stuff your country has to offer but we
want nothing to do with you. which again
goes back to the Islamic principle that
I was telling you, loyalty and enmity,
hatred for the non-Muslim, staying away
from them, being clean of them. Okay?
So, in and of itself, even if one didn't
want to uh appreciate what I'm talking
about, the deeper doctrinal historical
um dimensions to this, just the fact
that people come and they say we want to
be separate with our own exact our own
religion in and of itself should raise
question marks. Uh and and this is all
really, by the way, interconnected with
things like the Somali in Minnesota. Um
you know, these groups come here simply
so they can exploit and take, but they
want nothing to do with the whole
society. They they certainly don't want
to assimilate. Okay. And so even even in
that act, in that very aspect itself, I
think things are very obvious of what's
happening, but it's good that Texas um
and you are spearheading this movement
because this is very important uh to
kind nip it in the bud. And you know,
one of the problems right now that
Europe is going to face is facing no
matter what it does, is they can stop
all immigration tomorrow, they can say
no more, not a single one. But they're
stuck because they now have many
millions of Muslims living all of them
uh concentrated in rabbots or in
enclaves. And these are now problems
that they have to live with. Even though
a place like Hungary, where I'm where
I'm at currently, you know, nipped it in
the bud. They said, "No, we don't want
it." And they don't have it. And uh I
can walk out in the street and I see
people walking without fear uh the way
they are for example in Europe. So
hopefully America also learns uh from
this model and nips it in the bud.
>> Uh that's what this show is about. Peter
Movvena who's one of the top experts in
the United Kingdom and a guy that refers
to you all the time actually came to
Texas for a couple of weeks I think
before the holidays and then came back.
He was at our conference. uh he's got a
warning to Texans. He says, "Hey, look,
let me tell you something. In in the
same kind of time of development,
uh the the Islamic invasion of Texas is
much farther advanced than when it
started in England." He says they've
learned a lot like halal food. They've
created these businesses. They're
working together to to not just create
the business to hire people. They've got
school choice in Texas, which is paying
for these Muslim schools. He says people
in Texas got to understand this is
farther advanced than it was when it
started in England and much more
sophisticated. Your thoughts, sir?
>> Absolutely. And let's never lose sight
of the fact that all these organizations
are connected one way or another like
CARE and and the others are all
connected to the Muslim Brotherhood
which has rightly been um denounced as a
terrorist organization at least in
Texas. Um because they have written
documents that were captured by the FBI
which we still have which spell out
exactly what we're talking about and how
that is their master plan and their
blueprint. They literally say we are in
the in the west in the United States in
this case to sabotage their miserable
house. I'm literally quoting it through
a civilizational jihad which means not
through violence, not through the
classical jihad because that's not even
necessary. Nor is it possible. Muslims
are not going to conquer America by
violence. But we have all these uh
civilizational routes open to us
including through da including through
creeping Sharia which is what's
happening including through creating
these enclaves and proilitization and
all sorts of things. So it's important
to know that these groups we already
know what they're doing. We have their
documentation. We have their blueprint
because they are all born of the Muslim
Brotherhood and the Muslim Brotherhood
has said this and when you look at their
actions that is what they are doing. So,
it's there's no mystery involved and
it's it's high time for people to
actually be cognizant now than later or
you're going to end up like Europe and
that's not a good place to be.
>> Uh, we're going to have you on a lot
because you're I think one of the best
educators of people in the world. Uh,
you're a cop you're come from a long
line of Coptic Christians, correct?
>> Yeah, Coptic Christians. And, uh,
[clears throat] those are the indigenous
inhabitants of Egypt who are of course
all Christian.
And uh the very word Coptic actually
comes from the same word of Egyptian you
know Egypt gipped became cop. So when
the Arabs entered and conquered Egypt
they just dropped the first and last
syllable and called them the gipss and
we became known as the cop. So yeah it's
a it's an ethnic but it's also a
religious designation and they're the
descendants of the pharaohs. Actually, I
I like to remind people that even the
Coptic language, which still exists in
the liturgy, is the direct descendant of
the Feronic language, which has nothing
to do with Arabic, of course, even
though Arabic is today the primary
language of Egypt. Um, it's yeah, it's
it's the Coptic language. So, yeah, we
know a lot about Islam. We're about one
of the earliest groups of people who
encountered the jihadist sword, like I
said, right around 640. Um, this would
only be eight years after Muhammad's
death. and uh about 70 years before
Islam reached the you know France in the
battle of TS and um you know you fast
forward to now literally 14 centuries
and they're still the number one people
who tend to be uh maybe other than maybe
Christians in Nigeria and in other
subsaharan nations um the cops and the
other indigenous Christians like the
Assyrians
um in in Iraq and in Syria. But but hang
on. I want to go back. If we if we can
put up if we can put up the covers of of
his books cuz folks, I strongly
recommend you get all three books in
regards to this. You will hear that
you'll see the history of this invasion
uh not just in the west but throughout
the entire world. Number one, sword and
scimitar. You'll then uh his second book
was about the heroes that stood in the
breach of which people in this audience
are going to have to replicate those
heroes. Defenders of the West, which are
just incredible. And now you've got the
one about the military orders during the
Crusades, the Knights Hospital, the
Knights of St. John, and the Knights
Templars. Raymond, the books are
gripping. But I I just I want to leave
folks with the following.
Greatest state of Texas. And I say this
as a Virginia. And as a Virginia, you're
raised to think that Virginia is not
just the greatest state in the union,
but the union wouldn't exist if it was
not for Virginia. you know, it's called
the mother of presidents, you know, with
Washington and Jefferson and and even in
the Civil War, right? The the the
leaders of both sides. Um, so Virginia
takes a have are from small children are
imbued with this love of the
Commonwealth and how important it's been
in history. And I say this now as an
adult in my 70s that having traveled the
entire world and and have I have a
pretty good feel for geopolitics and
geoeconomics
uh and also the populist nationalist
movement that is kind of driven
throughout the world now that Texas is
unique. It is the jewel of the crown of
the American republic and the Islamists
have targeted Texas. It's different than
Dearbornne, Michigan, although they're
trying some of the same thing. It's
different than New York City, the
financial capital of the world. They
understand that if they can take over
Texas,
uh, they can basically take over the
American Republic and therefore change
world history. This is a very organized,
uh, very thoughtful plan to do this.
Don't think these people are dumb. They
are not dumb. They're very cunning and
they're very smart and that's why it's
got to be thwarted. Um, and I want to
leave people and Raymond jump in here.
They came out, these are better winds
that came out of a a wilderness, a
desert like you've never seen a desert
in your life. And in the matter of 70
years, they conquered Persia, Babylon,
uh Syria,
what is today uh you know, Israel, but
North Egypt, the ancient civilization,
most ancient civilization I think we
have even more than China, Egypt with a
very strong religious bent and North
Africa. I tell people I say St.
Augustine, probably the greatest of the
church fathers, was uh was a Berber out
of North Africa. They conquered North
Africa and were into Spain and came
within I think 150 miles of Paris where
they were stopped with by Charles
Martell. Uh Raymond, this came out of
the Middle East or came out of Saudi
Arabia uh on fire and they understand
that and that's why they're trying to
conquer the United States of America and
they're trying to do it through Texas.
Sir, your thoughts?
>> That's exactly right, Steve. Um, it's
it's that long painful history that most
people are unaware of that really
underscores everything we're talking
about and should make things very clear
because from the get-go from right from
the beginning once Islam started
spreading it was primarily against
Christian territories. The the exception
would be Persia, Zorastrian Persia, but
the rest of those areas that you
mentioned from greater Syria, Egypt all
the way westward overwhelmingly
Christian, Spain of course and then into
France. And so a great many conquests uh
were against and and that was just the
beginning. Then later on the Turks of
course took the Balkans and Asia Minor
and so forth. And so and you know you
fast forward. So speaking of America,
America's very first war people need to
remember this as a nation after it
gained independence was against Muslims
under the same exact logic. And uh I
think we can we can close with this
final, you know, anecdote of Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams who just don't
who didn't get it. They're enlightened
thinkers. And um here are Muslims from
North Africa who are attacking,
plundering, raiding American vessels,
enslaving American sailors. And
Jefferson and Adams meet with the um the
ambassador from Tripoli, one of the
barbar states, and they ask him, they
just say, "What? We we we don't count
anyone our enemy. We we don't provoke
anyone, and if no one provokes us, we
won't attack them. Why don't we trade?
Why don't we have business?" And he the
the the ambassador sounds just like
ISIS. He's he
Jefferson wrote a letter to Congress and
in the letter Jefferson says he told us
that our prophet says you're our enemy.
Our our Quran says we have to lay in
weight, ambush you, kill you, use
strategys and enslave you. And this was
of course he didn't know this Jefferson
but he was paraphrasing the Muslim Quran
95 which is known as the sword verse. So
it sort of makes sense when you fast
forward to today and you see all the
complications that Europeans are having
with Muslims and not just Europeans,
Australia, uh wherever you have, you
know, significant Muslim populations
living side by side with non-Muslims. As
Samuel Huntington said in his book, uh
you know, Islam's borders are bloody as
are its inards. Very true statement. So
you fast forward and you come to today
and you know Americans by nature are a
very uh hospitable people and they you
know they'll give you the benefit of the
doubt but I think they're starting to
learn um you know if not from history I
mean to me history just fills in the
gaps it gives us context it makes you
understand what's happening but they're
they're learning it the hard way just
the way the Europeans are learning it
the hard way that Islam is just at
variance at odds with everyone else
especially Christian western
civilization and it's not there to
coexist in its initial nassent stages.
Sure, it'll talk about just like
Muhammad did when he was weak, he had
his own strategim, which is when he was
weak, he preached uh tolerance and
freedom and cooperation, no coercion in
religion, etc. And when he became
strong, then all that tolerance went out
the window and it was basically the
sword, Islam or or or conversion or
vimitude. So you can expect that sort of
treatment if and when Muslims uh you
know reach that sort of critical stage
as they already are in parts of Europe.
Um you know Trump called it right when
he said that Europe is undergoing a
civilizational eraser. That's a very
important phrase that I think everyone
should be cognizant of and we don't want
to reach that point now. And like I said
it's always easier always better if you
can nip it in the bud early on rather
than wait and have it you know mushroom
to a huge problem. Think about places
like the UK and Germany and France. What
you know they have like 10 15% Muslim
population. So even if they end
immigration right now, this is something
they're going to always have to live
with. And uh I don't think we want to
reach that point.
>> No, it's terrible. I just want to remind
people uh the church started as a desert
church that totally got erased. Also,
these are ancient civilizations that had
their own religions. Persia, Babylon,
Syria, Egypt, North Africa, and
eventually they took Spain, I think, for
almost uh 800 or 900 years. Raymond, one
more time, if we can put the books up,
can you just walk through briefly each
book because I want the audience, if you
want to get educated, these are the
three best. They're highly readable and
and Raymond writes it in a way that
keeps you at the edge of your seat. What
is the first book? Sword and Scimitar.
What is that about?
>> Yeah, thanks Steve. So the first book is
Sword and Scimitar. The subtitle 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
West. And that one really uh follows the
history of Islam's annexation and
conquest of Western Christian Territory.
As I had been saying, Egypt and Syria,
all these nations that people seldom
think of as being western, well, they
were part of Christendom. Actually, they
were the older, richer, more uh learned
and sophisticated part of Christendom.
People forget. And they were all
violently conquered. Um so sword and
scimitar looks at that in the context of
the eight most decisive battles that I
talk about chronologically. So the first
one would be the battle of yarmmuk which
led to the conquest of Syria and Egypt
and the last one would be the siege of
uh Vienna in 1683. But I also talk about
the Barbrey uh wars that of America in
1801 1805 and then um the second book
would be defenders of the west the
Christian heroes who stood against
Islam. And this does it follows the same
trajectory but now through the lives and
the lens of these heroes eight heroes.
Uh so the sword and scimitar is eight
battles. This is eight heroes and I go
again chronologically. Uh so there are
many biographies eight mini biographies
of Christian warriors and their battles
against Islam. And I think there's a lot
to learn from that in and a lot of
inspirational material as well. And then
the newest book the two swords of Christ
uh which deals with the military orders
especially the templars and the
hospitalers and their wars against
Islam. that really and that's the
longest book and that one really if if
you're interested in the crusades this
is it because the templars and the
hospitalers were the backbone of the
crusade so virtually every crusade is
covered in detail but more importantly
and as captured by the title two swords
of Christ that of course is a reference
to the biblical verse in Luke where uh
where Jesus tells his disciples if you
don't have a sword go sell your garment
and buy one and then they say look Lord
here's two swords and he says that's
enough and you know to most modern
Christians, that verse means absolutely
nothing. You see, he's certainly not
talking about swords, which begs the
question, what's he talking about? Um,
to preodern Christians, especially
medieval Christians, and this comes out
very often in these books because they
would talk about these verses. That
verse meant you have two swords. One
against spiritual enemies, which we
still acknowledge, but one against
secular enemies, um, including the
Muslims.
>> Uh, Raymond, you're coming to us live
from Budapest. We appreciate it. social
media, where do people go and your
website?
>> Uh my website raymond.com
r a y m o n d i b r a h i m.com and I
also have a substack uh also just put my
name in and my website also has all the
links to my social media. I think uh
Ravenbrae 5 is my Twitter or or ex
account and uh so forth.
>> Thank you sir for joining us from
Budapest, a nation that did it right,
Victor Orban in Hungary. Thank you, sir.
Appreciate you.
[music]
>> The crusade.
Bring back the fire.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back [music] the fire and the
rightous name.